seguimos en france 24 con esta serie
sobre los recicladores en iberoamérica
hoy les contamos la situación de miles
de personas que buscan materiales
reciclables y comida en los basureros de
república dominicana la mayoría de ellos
son migrantes hay haitianos este
reportaje hace parte de la serie de
publicaciones resultados de la becada
producción periodística sobre reciclaje
inclusivo ejecutada con el apoyo de la
fundación gabo y la actitud de red
informe de carla pimentel
y república dominicana diez mil
recicladores escarban en los vertederos
a cielo abierto para sobrevivir como en
el vertedero de duquesa que recibe unas
cinco mil toneladas de basura del gran
santo domingo cada día algo estamos
máquina en la basura en un lodo esto era
basura todos los reyes hables para que
haya todo lo último como que dice del
mundo una comparación viene siendo lo
peor los aproximadamente 350 vertederos
que existen en el país caribeño la
mayoría de los recicladores son
nacionales haitianos como pensó que
llegaron al país en busca de mejores
condiciones de vida el año trabaja día y
noche
yo empecé a las 6 de la mañana a las 12
yo vine a comer a la 1 me sube hasta las
11 a las 12 de la noche porque yo estoy
buscando una manera para tiene algo va a
ser evaluada músico pensó ya tiene seis
hijos todos indocumentados como él vive
con sus compatriotas en la falda de la
gran montaña de basura que forma el
vertedero de duquesa a que nosotros
vivimos aquí
porque nosotros hago todo para que eso
de tal vez de dolor y también no
molestar a los otros en los próximos
meses los recicladores en república
dominicana esperan la promulgación de
una ley que busca por primera vez en la
historia del país su reconocimiento por
esta ley no otorgará estatus legal a los
recicladores haitianos indocumentados